(jazzy rhythmic music)
- [Voiceover] Yo, Chris.
- [Chris] Hey man, what's up?
- Not much, not much.
How was your weekend?
- [Chris] Um, I know
you don't really care.
You're just asking so I
ask you about your weekend.
Everybody knows you
went snowboarding, bro.
It's all over Instagram.
Go easy on the hashtags.
What about you?
How was yours?
- Oh, you know, it was cool, man.
Snowboarding up in Mammoth, fresh pow pow.
It was dope.
Here, check it out.
- You guys talking about the weekend?
Mammoth sounds fun.
Actually went to Disney
on Ice on Saturday.
- [Chris] This guy, he
always tries to relate to you
and be your friend, but
at the end of the day
he's still got a job to do.
- Anyway, I need 20
copies of this from you,
stapled and collated for
the meeting later, okay?
- [Chris] Sure.
(jazzy rhythmic music)
- [Chris] Alright, coffee.
- [Voiceover] Chris!
- [Chris] Hey...
What the hell is your name?
I wanna say it starts with a J.
Josh? Jamie?
I actually have to go make copies
for Shane's meeting later, so.
- Ah, stapled and collated (laughs)?
- [Chris] Shyeah, pretty much.
Okay, have a good one, dude.
- [No Name Guy] Peace bro!
- [Chris] I shoulda really
remembered his name.
(jazzy rhythmic music)
Crap, did she see me staring?
- [Woman] Hey, making copies?
- [Chris] Oh, yeah (laughs).
- You seem so tired.
- [Chris] Yeah, I'm
gonna get some coffee--
- You think you're tired, I'm exhausted.
I've been planning Dan's party all week.
- [Chris] Here he is, the planner.
Constantly inviting you and
your coworkers out for drinks,
food, a movie, but whatever
it is, you always come up
with an excuse.
Ah, see ya guys.
(jazzy rhythmic music)
- [Woman] What are you thinking about?
- Uh, I don't know.
I'm just glad I have
someone to talk to, I guess.
- Yeah, same.
- What?
- [Woman] Nothing.